im donbass befindet sich die sogenannte
kontakt linie dort stehen sich die
ukrainische armee auf der einen seite
und die prorussischen separatisten auf
der anderen seite gegenüber dort im
osten des landes wird geschossen die
osze hat allein am dienstag über 1000
explosionen gezählt wladimir putin hat
die unabhängigkeit der sogenannten
selbsternannten teilrepubliken jetzt und
lohans anerkannt und angekündigt die
russische armee zu schicken dann könnte
er zusammen mit pro russischen
separatisten die kontakt linie
überqueren das könnte zur folge haben
dass der ukrainische präsident bodo
miese lenski das kriegsrecht verhängt
der nationale sicherheitsrat jedenfalls
hat schon die verhängung des
ausnahmezustandes für 30 tage im
gesamten land angekündigt die eu und
nato länder haben jedenfalls bereits
sanktionen verhängt und die könnten noch
schärfer werden wenn die situation
weiter eskaliert deutschland jedenfalls
hat noch schnell zwei schon auf eis
gelegt